[Music]  huh  hey miss Ponce if you find this  recording don't feel bad about this part  of the journey use the end  [Music]  just the record being adrift in space  with zero promise of rescue is more fun  that sounds food and water went out four  days ago  officers will run out tomorrow morning  I've been when I drift off I will dream  about you it's always you  [Music]  thanos did  exactly what he said he was going to do  he wiped out  fifty percent of all living creatures  we lost all of us  lost friends as family  you lost a part of ourselves  this is the fight of our lives  this is good work Steve I know it is cuz  I don't know what I'm gonna do if it  doesn't  [Music]  hi anyone home this is Scott Lang we met  a few years ago at the airport in  Germany got really big is just an old  message and man and me I know you know I  know you know that  that's me can you buzz me in  you